[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
right
just a few hours ago our colleagues in
ukraine say missiles
struck at the center of cremenchuk which
had until recently now not been impacted
by the war a shopping mall was struck
authorities believe there may be large
number of civilians inside any attack
that hits a shopping mall is utterly
deplorable
during the weekend in the capital kiev
was hit again and a residential building
was damaged with some people trapped in
the debris missiles have also struck
areas in the west of the country far
from the front lines fighting also
continues in the donbass region where
our humanitarian colleagues are facing
tremendous challenges in reaching people
who are facing increasing needs the
challenges are not only due to
insecurity but also the lack of access
due to administrative restrictions
imposed by the parties
we once again stress
that the parties are obliged under
international humanitarian law to
protect civilians and civilian
infrastructure we don't have any numbers
on casualties yet
but it is deplorable to say the least
any sort of civilian infrastructure
which includes obviously shopping malls
and civilians should never ever be
targeted
um
we're obviously concerned about the
intensifying uh
fighting that we have seen uh we're
concerned for the civilians who are
being put at risk and who are being
killed and and wounded
we very much hope
that despite what is going on today
the talks
will continue and we will reach
we will reach
you